hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today an international
team of scientists concludes the current
drought in the Horn of Africa wouldn't
have happened without climate change
millions are threatened by floods in the
U.S as exceptional snow melt swells the
Mississippi River
and BP shareholders vote against the
re-election of its chairman in a revolt
against the scaling back of its climate
change targets
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis millions of people in the Horn of
Africa are facing famine as they enter
their fourth year of drought in Somalia
alone it's believed to have caused the
deaths of as many as 43 000 people last
year well now experts have concluded
that the drought wouldn't have happened
without climate change
scientists from the world weather
attribution group say that as a result
of human-induced climate change the
combination of low rainfall and high
evapotranspiration which is how much
water evaporates from soil and plants
because of higher temperatures well that
would not have led to Drought at all in
a 1.2 degree cooler World it goes on
climate change has made events like the
current drought much stronger and more
likely a conservative estimate is that
such droughts have become about a
hundred times more likely let's talk to
one of the reports authors Dr Mariam
zacharaches from the Grantham Institute
for climate change at Imperial College
London
um thank you so much for talking to us
just how much of an effect has
human-caused climate change had on this
particular drought
to understand the signal of climate
change we looked at three possible
definitions so in two of these cases we
looked only at uh the rainfall that uh
the rainfall event itself and then in a
third case we also looked at both
rainfall and the effect of temperature
now when we looked at rainfall uh we
could see that the region in the region
that we considered there are two
distinct rainfall Seasons so in the long
range season or the March April May rain
season there is a drying Trend whereas
for the October November December or the
short train season that the there is
there is no climate evident climate
change signal or rather there is a
wettening trend in in that and then we
also looked at because given that the
drought has been ongoing for uh five
continuous Seasons we also looked at uh
the rainfall over two years together and
in this case we saw that uh there is no
uh signal but then you know uh as as is
as with as as it just with climate
change that we also should consider the
effect of the regional warming and the
impact of regional warming on um
rainfall rainfall deficits and which is
why we look we considered the
combination of precipitation and uh the
potential evapotranspiration which is
important which determines the amount of
water that evaporates from the soil
through uh evapotranspiration now
looking at this we could see that uh
this combination of precipitation and
evapotranspiration would have been uh
have been made a hundred times more
likely in the current world as compared
to our world without climate change
okay so isn't the rainfall isn't the
area experiencing a lot of rainfall at
the moment will that help with what's
going on
um that so during the season uh yes so
at the on now that in May uh that's a
that's a linear forecasted and that is
supposed to uh bring the season uh it's
supposed to rain a little more but then
uh you know studies show that because of
the uh effects of this continuous
rainfall uh Seasons failing over the
last five seasons it will take time to
uh to overcome the uh or to to sort of
to uh to
um to reduce the the threats that is uh
currently uh the threats that the region
is currently faced with at the moment
okay Dr Mariam thank you so much for
talking to us
thank you
well some of today's other stories now
and a global team of scientists have set
themselves the goal of discovering a
hundred thousand new species in a decade
before they say overfishing and global
warming Drive entire populations to
Extinction ocean census has been funded
by Japan's Nippon foundation and the
uk-based Marine Research Institute
necton they plan to use Evolutions in
DNA extraction Gene sequencing machine
learning and artificial intelligence to
describe species at speed and scale the
ocean holds four billion years of our
evolutionary heritage
and this Priceless asset is now as we
all know at grave risk
it is a significant failure
in our generation stewardship
of the planet to know so little about so
much
ocean census objective is to redeem that
failure
if between us all
we fail in the task humans will die
and the ocean of course will survive
in the U.S Rising waters on the
Mississippi River are engulfing entire
neighborhoods and reaching what experts
call a major flood stage that's in Iowa
Minnesota and Wisconsin most of
California's Yosemite Valley will be
closed to visitors from this weekend and
Iowa's third largest city is embraced
for major flooding more potentially
damaging flooding is expected in the
coming weeks as the snow from this
year's bumper season continues to melt
and the King has approved the first
Royal gold medal for architecture of his
Reign the winner is a champion of zero
carbon self-built houses for displaced
people Professor Yasmin Larry as
Pakistan's first female architect and
her work has seen the creation of 50 000
sustainable shelters the medal she's won
is awarded to those who've had a
significant influence on the advancement
of architecture
beefy's annual general meeting has been
interrupted by multiple protesters some
of whom have been carried out at the
venue by security Now the oil giant is
facing a Revolt by shareholders who are
voting against the re-election of its
chairman after its climate change
targets were cut five UK Pension funds
are involved in the Revolt including
Nest the government's workplace pension
scheme
now Katarina lindmeier is the senior
responsible investment manager at Nest
she joins us now Katarina thank you so
much for talking to us so what are you
hoping to achieve by this vote because
it hasn't changed their emissions
targets has it
ultimately this is a vote to register
our concern with the direction of travel
this is really an unprecedented
situation we've not yet seen a company
set fairly ambitious climate targets and
then only nine months later wrote back
on them and what's been even more
disappointing to us is that while bpe
consulted on its initial shorter medium
term oil and gas production targets at
the last AGM when they made the decision
to change the Targets in February this
year they did not commit to bring them
back to an investor vote we have engaged
with BP privately on this and asked the
company to offer shareholders another
vote and they refused to give us that
opportunity we've therefore escalated
our engagement to vote against the chair
to register Our concern with the process
and the governance around this decision
so there are five big Pension funds
voting against him including yours but
you represent less than one percent of
the company's shares do you really think
you're going to make a difference with
this vote
we actually represent over a third of
the UK Workforce so we do have a large
share of members behind this decision
the main aim of this is to register that
concern and to get BP to speak to us
about the decision and bring this back
to our shareholder vote
why don't you just invest elsewhere if
you're trying to make a statement why
don't you just pull your funds and
invest elsewhere
we invest in a broad range of companies
but we really think that BP needs to be
part of the transition and we want BP to
be a long-term sustainable holding for
our members we therefore think it's
really important that we use the
opportunity that we have as a
shareholder to engage with a company and
to use the voting rights that we get at
the annual general meeting to challenge
the board and hold them to account on
their commitment to Net Zero well BP
have said that it values constructive
Challenge and engagement have they
engaged with you on this at all
we have had engagement with BP on this
issue and we continue to speak to the
company about it but crucially while BP
has previously submitted targets to a
shareholder vote they have not done so
with this particular decision and we
believe it's heading in the wrong
direction for the company and not taking
into account the long-term Financial
risks that climate change poses and the
need to transition within this decade
and this is why we've taken the decision
to escalate our engagement by voting
against the re-election of the chair and
what happens if nothing happens and they
stick to their new targets what will you
do then
there are other opportunities for
investors to escalate engagement of
course we hope to continue the dialogue
with BP and we hope to see them set more
ambitious climate Targets in future but
we have previously divested from
companies where we haven't seen the
progress that we would have liked from
engagement for example about a year and
a half ago we divested from the U.S
Energy company ExxonMobil after three
year engagement process did not bring
sufficient progress in their approach to
managing climate change risk okay
Katarina thank you so much for talking
to us
thank you
and just to say we did approach BP for a
comment but received no response to the
pension fund's criticisms now before we
go a reminder that you can watch the
climate Show with Tom Heat this weekend
that's on Saturday and Sunday at 3 P.M
and then again at 7 30 pm
thank you so much for watching that's
all from us today goodbye
[Music]